how you doing there bud I'm fine great
well I hear your mouth say that but the
rest of your head is telling a different
story feels like the stress of the
upcoming trial is starting to get to you
oh it's just about my hair turning white
yes definitely it's not just the head
hair
it's all of it
all
I get it it's like an Eagles concert
down there nothing but whites understood
you got white pubes there's no need to
stress out the lawyer is very confident
not good enough I need to do everything
I can to save Jake Charles you're
falling apart and that's not helping
anyone you need to get your crap in
order
okay
yeah you're right
I'll take a nap
I'll eat
I'll dye my pubes you can dye all your
hair now there's no time
I'm gonna go check in on Sharon make
sure she's not pushing prematurely
fatiguing the uterus okay wait you can't
talk to her
Terry doesn't want you in there
you make her uncomfortable
I make her uncomfortable
well that's ridiculous
I should go confront her about this at
length no wait you could but I think
that would probably stress her out and
we're trying to keep her calm right now
so maybe just
focus on work
of course
I only want to help whatever is best for
sharing really you're fine with that
absolutely I don't take it personally I
mean it's about me and my behavior
specifically nobody else not Hitchcock
or Scully but yeah I'm fine
what a joyous occasion
he's looking at us pretend he's the ice
machine Boyle gladly
why is it so funny at hotel ice
that was wasteful but also like I bought
this room I deserve this ice
okay I'll follow to the acpd get here
damn it stay put for also don't worry
I'm just gonna let Serge follow him I'm
gonna stay right here I can't do it I'm
gonna cut him off in the alley
shortcut you just got James
oh Jake
you okay
nose hurts I got hit by a car
oh
you're happy now broken ribs and a
million broken toes weren't enough for
you in retrospect they were plenty yes
the worst part is Olson got away that's
the worst part you could have died man I
wasn't hurt that badly the doctor said
all my bleeding was internal that's
where the blood's supposed to be
the only way out of this hole is to keep
digging that's not how holes work title
your sex tape Charles look you're gonna
find your way out of this I swear it's
all gonna work out you're right you know
if I just work hard and stay positive
I'm sure it'll be a huge success and
everything will be okay there you go
hello oh okay
no thank you
so my truck burned down that was your
first dent in Solitaire it was nothing I
held it together oh
Amy when did you get here you've come
for my conjugal capabilities
you're lucky I'm not a real good girl
how's the booby no matter
I'll just build another one more mashed
potatoes
all right everyone calm down just calm
down let us out bro I'm gonna stop
breaking things this is a human rights
violation you can't keep us here I'm 23.
I'm a celebrity and today I'm gonna die
not one word if that is true
oh Hitchcock's bleeding he got hit in
the head with a soda can he never saw it
coming Jake we have to start putting
people in detention you have to wash
this no we need them to calm down we
need to put on Something's Gotta Give
great idea great movie also we should
probably put out that fire
thank you
so captain
I have some news what happened well
remember when you told me not to burn
down the precinct you burned down the
precinct no I had the fire put out
almost immediately this is a success
story tell me exactly what happened well
it started with Boyle wanting to say the
word succulent oh no and it ended with a
small riot in which a dirtbag set
Hitchcock's snap couch on fire okay so
those guys look down on you so what I
mean Amy's parents look down on me they
talk about me right in front of my face
in Spanish because they don't think I'm
smart enough to learn another language
but I've been taking classes and now I
can understand all the hurtful things
they've been saying and how did that
help well now I know they think I'm
short and I was able to do some research
and find that 1940 census that proves
I'm above average in height for 1940.
yeah I'm taller than the greatest
Generation it doesn't matter
to get Landon not stand now what why and
how would you describe the lieutenants
he works for Hawkins he put
them on Melanie Hawkins was the most
honorable cop I ever worked with and the
only reason I am here is because of that
man Jake Peralta he offered me three
hundred thousand dollars to lie and say
that she set him up
okay okay this is bad this is really bad
but just remember we are not going to
jail we didn't do it we're innocent
guilty on all charges
guilty
very cool
cool cool cool cool cool cool cool cool
cool cool
cool cool cool cool cool
I want you to follow her and make sure
she doesn't betray us and uh don't tell
Peralta Count Me In I got nothing else
going on aren't you supposed to be
getting ready to transfer to Staten
Island that's not real it's pretty real
last week that's before I decided to
pretend it wasn't
I'm in denial most people who are in
denial don't usually say they're in
denial that's because they're in denial
about being in denial but I'm not in
denial I'm in denial is Shepherd's brain
okay for this Mission yes sir for this
and all future 99 missions which I'll
definitely be a part of let's go a
member of the commissioner selection
committee is coming in today to tour the
precinct and do some interviews would
you mind speaking with her of course
Terry loves answering the hard questions
here she is I guess you don't have time
to take off those ridiculous suspenders
what hello Miss Sumter hello Captain I'm
excited to speak to your subordinates
and learn more about your management
style I thought you could talk to
Sergeant Jeff is here Sergeant oh um I'd
rather not talk to a supervisor I was
hoping to interview one of your
detectives perhaps um
him
no excuse me there was a wasp near me
which has since disappeared you can
interview detective Hitchcock and I am
completely fine with that
all right bye Christmas is going to be
amazing
suck I don't have the present what but
you promised the collage I ordered it a
month ago from a Latvian Toy Story and
it still hasn't arrived yet the shipping
company has given me the runaround all
right so just get him a different
present like a jet ski or a hammer I
don't know what kids are into Genevieve
and I worked so hard to get Nikolai
should trust us when we brought him home
oh that's going to be destroyed the way
dry rot destroyed his orphanage trust me
it's gonna be fine really
you said that about Die Hard 5 Jake
oh
it's not gonna be fine
another cold brew don't mind if I cold
do nailed it I am loving this machine
that Charles brought in it is nice the
trick is to let the coffee warm up to
room temperature I'm already on my
second cup this is my third
turkey
turkey wow what's going on Charles why
are you talking so slow I'm not
[Music]
foreign
anyway whatsoever I feel like we're
going slow in every way whatsoever
Captain how do you feel great excellent
amazing I feel better never felt it in a
moment in my entire life so we're all
fine yep yep yep yep yep yep yep